hello and welcome to our webinar on
digital marketing predictions based on
trends in this hour we're going to be
helping you kick off your 2019 marketing
success with an experts look back and
what worked and what didn't in 2018 I'm
Dan B Vener I'm simple instructor of
training research and your moderator
today and it is my pleasure to introduce
you to our esteemed guest Matt Bailey
Matt Bailey is the best-selling author
marketing expert a corporate trainer and
professional speaker he's the founder
and president of site logic marketing
matt is the digital marketing instructor
for the Direct Marketing Association in
New York City is a member of the digital
marketing faculty for simply learned and
he's an instructor for the mCP that's
the online marketing certified
professional program he is the author of
internet marketing an hour a day from
2011 wired to be wowed
and most recently teach new dogs old
tricks
nomad excels in combining his marketing
background with programming know-how so
he's going to be sharing a lot of that
information with us today so I just want
to say happy new you're Matt and welcome
Hey thanks Dan it's pleasure to be here
well it's good to have you Matt and I
are going to be having a sort of a
candid conversation about the key
lessons learned over the past year it's
looking ahead and I just want to say
that you're all invited to join in with
your own questions and observations
through a Q&A to get this conversation
started here's a preview of some of what
Matt and I will be talking about today
first of all is going to be influence
for marketing then social media
and what's new on the horizon for that
paid search customer experience and
finally personalization how that brings
it in and then some other topics that
may have come up during the midst of
this webinar and of course looking
forward to your feedback as well so with
that I'd like hand the mic over to Matt
and get us started with influencer
marketing how are you doing Matt I'm
doing well and yeah I've been looking
forward to this for a while there's just
been a load of information over the past
few months just analyzing
some of the trends what's working what's
not working so this is I've been looking
forward to this and kind of sharing some
of the data as you've got here the the
influencer marketing I think has been a
very interesting thing to watch over the
past few years it's very interesting
because this was like the big shiny
object last year it only became shinier
as the year went on but then some little
you know chinks in the armor here and
there things started to kind of fall
apart main reason is I could divide
influencers into three different areas
there are the macro influencers which
reach you know like 5 to 10 million
people subscribers or followers or more
those are typically your celebrities
actors singers athletes other type of
personalities but then you have your
micro influencers micro influencers are
about a hundred thousand to 1 million
followers or subscribers and and that's
kind of your mid-range there you've got
a lot of bloggers you have a lot of
twitch streamers instagramers a lot of
the the industries are in gaming and
fashion and food and after that are what
now is being called nano influencers and
this is becoming the shiny object within
the shiny object nano influencers are
less than 10,000 however due to the
nature of what they do typically you'll
see nano influencers in photography
fashion home decor DIY programming
reviews things tech marketing design
they tend to be very niche focused
publishers of content and it can be
through blogs vlogging instagramming I
there's all kinds of different ways that
people are influencing and so really it
just kind of comes down to the thing
that almost anybody is an influencer by
definition
because it's just a matter of who you
influence and then that gets back to the
what became one of the larger problems
with influencer marketing is how
influential is the influencer what what
do they really move when it comes to
affecting people and so while your macro
influencers are making millions of
people with a video or with their posts
was it really moving the dial on sales
or in getting new subscribers and when
you start to look at the numbers as far
as what was generated and your cost per
sale or your cost per acquisition and
you compared that to other channels such
as paid search such as organic search or
some of your other more established
programs the influencer marketing was
way out of reach when you did a per per
sale or per acquisition look especially
on that macro level because the cost was
you know upwards of around $10,000 us
for creating a video to be published on
YouTube for a brand and so that became a
big issue as far as the escalating rates
that your macro influencers were
charging also which became a problem as
well is that 90 percent of macro
influencers that are celebrities in any
way singers actors athletes 90% of them
are not marking their paid uh their paid
marketing as an ad it means that if
they're receiving any money if they're
receiving any consideration or product
they need to disclose that in their
posts or in their videos or in their
posts they if they don't disclose that
that is a problem with the FTC and with
Mo
governments around the world because it
is a matter of consumer protection so
about 90% of your macro influencers are
not marking paid ads as ads they're not
disclosing the relationship probably one
of the biggest things that happen in the
past year is that Unilever announced
that it will no longer utilize
influencers that purchase followers and
it it's been estimated that nearly half
of influencers are buying followers
it's not hard to go online and find
services where you can buy followers and
you can buy likes you can buy Instagram
likes you can buy YouTube likes you can
buy YouTube followers and likes if
there's a social media you can buy
followers and likes and honestly the
price is not that bad I think one of the
prices I saw that if you want 5,000
followers it will only cost you $40 now
it's amazing how many people are doing
this because if you have more followers
then you can demand more money from
influence or marketing so you can buy
these and honestly the other side of
this industry is that it creates literal
digital sweatshops where click farms are
right now in third world countries
becoming sweatshops where people sit
around and click and follow on thousands
of phones in a warehouse and they're
only being paid pennies to do this and
so it's there isn't a kind of a seamy
underbelly going on here now because of
that you yeah you know are there any
tools you're going to get to this but
someone's asking is there any tools
people can use to determine whether or
not the follower account of a particular
social media influencers is necessarily
bona fide like other other tools out
there that you can choose to see that oh
this this might be just a bunch of bots
yeah there are tools there are some
auditing tools that are out there and
also
look the social media themselves are
trying to purge these accounts when they
find them the main issue is it's very
similar to you know ad fraud and just
about any other industry the better the
tools get to detect the fake accounts
the better the fake accounts get and so
it's kind of an arms race as to you know
if there is a demand someone's going to
supply that demand and they're going to
develop the technology to look like
legitimate followers or users when
they're not because the demand is there
so yeah there there is technology to do
it it's not perfect at this point um so
yeah what Unilever did is they announced
they're not going to utilize any
influencers that if it's proven or shown
that they are purchasing followers and
essentially they get blacklisted at the
same time after spending tens of
millions of dollars on influencer
marketing they really pulled back and
they are really waiting all of their
influencer initiatives they're also
auditing their agency relationships
they're now down to a third of the
agencies that they use last year they're
bringing a lot more things in-house a
lot more expertise in-house but
ultimately they're auditing their ad
spend and how it will be used is real
interesting Avinash Kaushik over at
Google Analytics he calls influencer
marketing a faith-based marketing that
it's an incredibly non accountable way
of marketing he has some pretty strong
opinions about that and I agree with
much of them I think what you will see
is uh influencer marketing moving into
something that's much more tangible a
much more focused because what's
happening here is the larger the
influencer you work with the less brand
control you have uh and then how do you
distinguish what you are asking people
to do for your brand
from you know one of the biggest terms
to come up in the past you
yours is fake news and sometimes we are
seeing fake news equated with
non-disclosed ads from influencers and
so your brand has to draw a line there
and then what happens if the brand or
the influencer you're working with does
something wrong there are numerous
examples of influencers who have just
gone off the tracks and the brand then
has had to scramble and respond to that
so what do you do in response to that
the best influencer campaigns that I
have seen run is where the brand finds
an influencer who's already a fan of the
product or of that company and that that
influencer already has a platform and
that platform is related to that product
or that industry and so and typically
they would be then defined as your input
they're somewhere between ten thousand
or less than a hundred thousand
followers but finding those influencers
that they like your product already and
they'd be more than happy to pitch for
it and if they get compensation for it
in some way of shape or form they'll be
even more happy so finding that right
cohesion there and then also their
followers have to be willing to listen
when this influencer says they're being
paid to present this content as an ad -
many times influencers will put it out
there and then later their followers
find out that it was an ad or they were
paid to do that
does it go over too well so it's finding
the right influencer who knows your
brand
I believe it and they're already a fan
of it and that way when they do talk
about it it's going to be genuine and
chances are they've already talked about
the brand when they work getting
consideration for it so then as they
move on and maybe they are getting
consideration then their followers will
be probably more open especially if it
is
schon and they're being upfront that
they're receiving compensation for it so
that's really where I think influencer
if it's going to survive that's how it's
going to happen is you know we're always
going to have the company the big
companies with deep pockets spending
money with the macro influencers the the
big names with millions of followers
that's going to happen because they've
got the money to do it but small
businesses medium-sized businesses other
companies what I see is they're trying
to avoid the large-scale influencers and
instead they're focusing on smaller ones
that they can work more with and control
the brand message even more right and of
course be very careful with the future
of that too because I know there have
been some cases where where influencers
have for example in the in the
e-cigarette side had been really
proponents of the product and then later
on change their mind about it and so
it's sometimes it can write ways on you
yeah and that's the thing they may take
you know they may take the job for the
money uh but then after some pressure
they may give in and you know you know
stop so again it comes down to you know
I look at were they a fan of this to
start or am i paying them to say
something nice you know especially with
you know two to three years ago the
blood work buzzword was authenticity I
haven't heard that as much recently and
I think it has something to do with
influencer marketing of course I'm you
contain your personal relationships well
with them as well so that you don't give
them any men and pay them when you say
you're going to or anything absolutely
that relationship intact uh the better
so absolutely cool what's going on we're
in the world of social media now social
media I hesitate to use this word social
media you know was the disruptive
influence in traditional media and now I
think social media is going to go
through disruption in itself it's
interesting the studies that are coming
out
especially among Gen Z and younger users
a there is a large percentage of them
who don't want anything to do with
social media and it's so interesting
because these generations have grown up
as digital natives they've seen their
parents they've seen siblings on social
media and when you read some uploads
about what they say about it and they
seem to go around with I don't want to
play the game I don't want the pressure
I don't want to have to maintain there's
a real almost kind of a rebellion going
on about that among the younger users
now also currently in social media
radium 1 is a social media listening
program company they're estimating right
now that over 80% of sharing takes place
on what they call dark social now dark
social it may sound sinister it just
means like SMS or private chats which
the users are not comfortable anymore
putting their opinions out in public
instead they're using SMS in group chats
or an individual chats or they are
moving to more anonymous platforms such
as reddit or discussion forums where
they don't have to publish their real
name and so I think a lot of this also
has to do with you know there is a
waning trust in platforms specifically
Twitter and Facebook you know the
Facebook's inability to control fake
news but also the overstepping of
privacy in so many areas it's really
kind of created this interesting
position now where people will either
use Facebook and Twitter very limited
but we see more of this migration to
more anonymous or offline or dark
channels to share information its
interests
because the average time for a user on
Facebook plateaued years ago Facebook
cannot get the average time per user per
day to grow and they haven't been able
to do it for years the stories which
works great on Instagram doesn't work
well on Facebook they have to rely on
the feed which is where ads and fake
news thrive and that reduces trust so
again you know I think this is probably
a third or fourth time I talked about
trust and I think that is part of the
reason we're going to see a lot of
disruption especially in the big players
Facebook Twitter uh we're not seeing it
so much in YouTube now although they do
have some crosscurrents
kind of coming in with digital rights
and copyrights and things like that a
lot of your producers of content on
YouTube are really feeling some pressure
there so that's part of I think part of
the as one user said I'm exhausted from
social media and more and more I think
I've seen and also talked to people
online who have decided just to what
they say create commit social media
suicide and move more towards anonymous
platforms well you know I've noticed
statistics about it as well just because
as a marketer always having to keep
track of what the biggest thing is and
I'm really surprised particularly
worldwide that it seemed like the last
time I checked the number one platform
for social was whatsapp yeah and so in
just like you're saying more the SMS
type focus and I think just like you're
saying trust has really eroded in terms
of of Facebook especially I've been even
hearing the term the my specification of
Facebook where it's almost like it would
used to be a great platform and and now
it's sort of been taken over by
commercial interests so people keep
forgetting in fact that if it's if it's
free you're the product
well it's interesting cuz I I have my
own research department here I have
three teenage girls and so that could be
an insight a very unique insight into
social media and I'll tell you what what
they and their friends are doing right
now the oldest one has an Instagram
account but it's private and it's only
for friends and then she has started one
for work and for kind of her own little
business that she's starting the rest of
them are all about SMS direct messaging
and I tell you that the two platforms
that they spend the most amount of time
on our YouTube and Pinterest and that
blows my mind because Pinterest is
almost their go-to place uh for just
about anything it's almost a they're
going to Pinterest more than they're
going to Google a lot of times in order
to find recipes pictures information
it's really interesting to see really
how they and their friends are using
things that I wouldn't you know you know
when it comes to looking up a recipe i I
would go to a search engine and they go
to Pinterest right well how is this
affecting that's great for business to
consumer and for for people
communicating with each other but what's
the what's the best what are the best
approaches that businesses can find
particularly when they're going in the
b2b aspect in terms of social I find
where people are talking you know forums
I am amazed how much forms have been
neglected in digital marketing because
every year or two we have a new shiny
object and everyone follows over I'm
amazed how the lasting power of
discussion forms there are even still
some email lists discussion lists that
are out there but really the thing is is
fine where people are talking about
these things
where are they sharing information and
how is that happening and you'll find
you know some b2b uh they really have
some strong
presence in different areas because
people will find a way to share
information that they can't get from the
brands and getting like real comparison
data or how do I make this happen within
this setup it's really uh fascinating
where you can get some of that uh one of
the things when I was going to be to be
one of the things that was invaluable is
doing a user group of our customers and
learning from them where do you get
additional information where do you go
when you've got a question because you
know we were one provider but they had
probably 50 or 60 providers for the
entire workflow so you know interviewing
them about how they get information then
that can point you in the right
direction to find some of those online
resources that they get yeah well so
someone is asking specifically about
snapchat and where that's playing into
the social media sphere for 2019 um you
know what I think snapchat is kind of
that uh they play second to Instagram
I've not seen strong engagement or
strong numbers come out of it especially
considering why and how it was started
and a purpose I think a lot of those
that know the story of snapchat really
have an aversion to using it and I think
also you know I think they're it's kind
of up and down but I really don't see
them unless they kind of remake
themselves I don't see them really
pulling ahead of Instagram or some of
the other social media right now there's
someone else is asking just a waning of
social media include b2b via LinkedIn
like how was I was I was LinkedIn
playing ah yeah I you know LinkedIn um
I'm blown away by LinkedIn especially
some of the things that they've done in
the past few years
uh the acquisition of lynda.com and now
they linked in learning addition it's
becoming really your professional
face online I I think that is going to
continue to grow stronger because from a
b2b standpoint there's nothing like it
that enables those connections and
enables you to reach people uh now the
one thing that will get LinkedIn is uh
you know I've also seen an increase in
the amount of people that want to
connect with you and automatically make
it a sales channel or get a sales pitch
that's going to turn people off um you
know getting ten sales pitches a day
through LinkedIn is not anyone's idea of
fun
and so LinkedIn is going to have to
somehow they keep that under control
because you know a social platform does
have to have that element of curiosity
of fun and if I've got to deal with
sales pitches all day you know I'm not
going to be as integrated in it but
LinkedIn I don't see any sense at this
point of going backwards in fact going
exactly the opposite they are growing
and growing worldwide it's really cool
to see yeah I guess the probably
someone's offering that probably the
best thing they need to work on next
year is they have a lot of work to do on
their paid platform like campaign
manager but we're doing well and that's
what it's what's interesting and so
doing campaigns on LinkedIn the results
you will pay more and get less results
on LinkedIn the main reason is
especially from b2b everyone's seen it
before
they know it's an ad they know they're
being sold to and so you'll get good
visibility you'll get good impressions
you might even get some clicks but the
conversions from LinkedIn are very very
low and it mainly because who you're
targeting everybody else is targeting
and you know they've seen it and so to
work on LinkedIn takes a real dedicated
effort and you just can't do the typical
campaign and let it run there's got to
be ongoing follow-up retargeting
redeploying it takes
as an effort because you're talking to
people they get like I said they're
getting 10 sales pitches a day from
LinkedIn so you've got to distinguish
yourself yeah well with that brief touch
on campaign managers it's a good time to
move on to a paid search absolutely
absolutely
it's similar to what I just said on
LinkedIn is just right now going out and
buying keywords and putting an ad up
developing a landing page and that's
great but that's only about 20% of what
your total campaign needs to cover if
that's all you're doing you may get some
business you may have a profitable
campaign but anymore if you are going to
develop a paid search campaign you need
to look at what is the customer journey
what are people looking for and when am
I getting them early in the buying cycle
and if so if they come to my landing
page and probably not convert am i
retargeting to take advantage of that
and I'm on retargeting with the right
message to move them to the next stage
of research if I know people are
researching and they come to my landing
page what can I offer them that helps
them research and doesn't oversell how
do I move them to that next stage give
them the information they need so it's
really breaking down these stages but
then also post purchase what are people
going to be searching for post purchase
that I can reach them and maybe upsell
or cross-sell or enable them or educate
them about how they can get more out of
their campaigns uh it's really I you
know paid search and social are all now
it's going to become a matter not so
much of I've got a big idea and I'm
going to go to a campaign it's what's
your big plan not your big idea
but what's your big plan and then it's
going to come down to how well do you
execute that plan and then how well are
you following through executing that
plan are you doing
the details that were in that plan the
problem is is when you just approach
social or paid search and you do the
basic campaign that's just not going to
work moving forward it's going to take a
serious commitment to understanding the
customer what they need when they need
it and answering those questions as they
go through it and measuring every step
of the way so that's really you know
where
paid search is going to require more
commitment from advertisers but here's
the payoff uh people rely on search now
more than ever
monthly active users the number of
searches are increasing dramatically
around the world Google came out with a
number late last year the 84 percent of
Americans are shopping for something all
the time and in up to six different
product categories I mean that's that is
astounding that most Americans are
shopping for six things at any given
moment in time uh you know I would look
at your if you're on Google if you know
Google account go to your account look
at your history and look at the past
things that you have searched for just
in the past two days I guarantee you
there is a lot of information in there
product information what are you looking
for what are you shopping for but also
people are integrating themselves on a
more personal level with search so you
know we talked a little bit about voice
assistance and voice search the amount
of searches that are becoming more
personal and by that I mean they're
using the words near me the phrase near
me has increased 200%
for the past two years year-over-year
people searching for something near me
the word I is being used uh more often I
think it's up sixty-five percent this
year over last year which
and that was about 50% uh near me uh and
we're seeing people searching for more
personal things using personal words
such as uh you know what shampoo is best
for me
what dog food is best for me it's
interesting how people are integrating
themselves into the search and looking
you know remembering on search to
provide very personalized
recommendations yeah I was seeing how
conversational search queries and the
whole popularity of the assistance like
Google and Siri and Lux are changing SEO
like that compared to the days when
people just typed in queries to be able
just talk into their phones and we'll
probably get into that a little bit
later but how is that how is that really
affecting what in Italy you know
anything it's just when people type in
near me and especially when they're on
their phones they don't need to do that
um I don't know how because Google takes
care of that anyway if they know where
you are you're going to get results
based on that so it's interesting to see
where people are using that so much but
it's important from a local business
standpoint is understanding what are
people searching for around you and how
do you then position yourself to get
that visibility when people are
searching for your business when they're
searching for things to do places to eat
things to visit understanding those
words that people are using them and how
they're using them but then also what
we're seeing in searches people are
searching for uh advice so like the ten
best or the best products for this or
the best brands for this so people want
more research in comparison information
and that's how they're searching in
order to make their decision and also
how to prepare themselves in order to
make the best decision yeah that's a
that's a great point especially since to
it I think the review aspect is having
a big pull into a two because people are
really spending a lot more effort and
looking at reviews rather than
necessarily a lot of search ads and yeah
and other types of organic and another
organic type of search results
absolutely that is a big part of it and
well I know I myself I do a lot of
travel and my cattle Yelp is my you know
that's my guidebook okay you know I
followed that pretty closely mm-hmm now
before we move on security before we
move on to the next section I have one
question looks pretty interesting here
about how do you with all these changes
coming up what's a good suggestion as to
how you can staffed a resource to
execute these more complex plans
particularly on the paid search side now
you see a lot see a lot of changes in
how more traditional marketing teams
have the structure and hire in order to
adapt to the digital transformation
requirements particularly in business to
business in business to business well
and I've seen this take place now in
some larger enterprise companies where
they're creating smaller teams to handle
specific specific channels or specific
campaigns for example a paid search
campaign now I need someone who can
handle the creative I need someone who
can make the buy I need someone who can
analyze the numbers but I also need
someone who can create specific plans or
scenarios of here's how we're going to
reach this and here's how we're going to
reach this person and here's how we're
going to reach these keywords and these
ideas and they plan them out and then
you have your content person they're
creating the ads they're creating the
landing pages and then you're working
with your ad buyer your you're working
with you know a small team to make that
happen but then that team is also
day-to-day watching the campaign
watching it unfold and saying what can
we improve how do we do this and so I
the companies that I have seen really
excel
this it's less management and more
teamwork from the different discipline
areas that are able to execute make
decisions change try fail move and it
because what's more dynamic process
because we're focused on this and we're
going to make this happen and we've got
all all the pieces that we need all the
players that we need in order to you
know get this campaign up and running
quickly but also adjust quickly that's
what I've seen is really kind of the
future of working in these different
channels right well great advice I just
have one more question the paid side and
that is do you see Google moving into
the ABM space within ads I'm sorry Dan
what was that account based marketing oh
okay ooh wow that's interesting um I
know a lot of times well anytime you set
up and add within Google they want to
get their team involved and especially
the more money you spend the more
pressure you're going to get from Google
to help manage your campaign um I have
some issues with that I don't always
think that the people you talk to have
the most experience in it so I you know
obviously they want you to spend but
more and more I have seen more
enterprise level companies as well as
SMBs realize that rather than just have
the agency do everything and cut a check
every month they need to have in-house
expertise in paid search that understand
what's going on what makes it happen and
how to evaluate a campaign so that they
can get the most out of their search
that goes back to what Unilever is doing
in bringing more expertise in-house
rather than relying on the agency to do
it all so that you've got people who can
ask the right questions in-house and
make that evaluation and make that
determination what needs to happen so I
hope I answer the question correctly you
know with the with the account
management but I
from high level to mid-level what I'm
seeing is people are relying on training
their own people or bringing in
expertise so that decisions are made
with the interest of the company with
more expertise and understanding of how
to get the most out of these accounts
right well I know one way to get most of
it out of accounts as a segue here is to
improve the customer experience we're
all so let's that lead us into that and
what we can look forward to in 2019 all
right I am so excited about customer
experience I love doing a lifecycle or
customer lifetime analysis or customer
journey I love doing that stuff because
I tell you what every time I work with a
company on their customer journey there
has been thousands of dollars discovered
it's just thousands of dollars on the
table that because everyone is doing
their job but not looking at the big
picture something's always left behind
and so when you get a group of people
into the room and you look at that
entire customer journey you see some of
the holes and those holes are sometimes
where we're dropping the ball with
customers where we're not make a
connection with them we're not
communicating well and so the experience
people used to say you know SEO is king
or content is king I'm going to go with
experience is king if there's one thing
that will transcend any type of
marketing its experience because if you
work with a company and they do what
they say they'll do and their product
does what they say it'll do but then
they go the extra mile to make sure that
you're happy to make sure that you're
getting the most out of it and you know
assisting you and providing additional
education you know what you're going to
go out of your way to go back to them
the next time or you know there's a
subscription you're going to be more
than happy to say yes I'm going to Reese
absque ribe because I can't live without
it the entire customer experience right
now can be measured modeled and you can
magnify each individual piece to find
what's happening where are we failing
where can we improve and what will be
the measured response if we improve and
so engaging in that will enable you to
retain existing customers at a higher
rate and also onboard new customers and
engage them right away because right now
customers sight experience as the
biggest factor for brand loyalty so you
know and that experience that starts
with search it starts with you know it
starts with when people have a problem
and how do you give them that
information it extends into social how
you engaging educating how you
developing your customers and how are
you communicating with them over the
long term not just to get them as a
customer I think I saw a study somewhere
that like 70% of brand communications
are all in pre-sales
that only 30% or less of brand
communications are from a post sale
perspective and that is what will kill
the customer experience part of that
aspect of creating a good customer
experience also includes personalization
well absolutely moving forward with that
personalization you know it's as simple
honestly as putting someone's name in a
subject line or you know in a document
but personalization is not just about
putting my name in something it's a
little bit more than that
personalization is about is this message
relevant to me right now
that's a personalization is all about so
you know we can get into you know AI
chatbots you know
personas demographics but really what it
comes down to is how are you
personalizing things right now
you know I in this slide here how do you
make that customer feel special what are
you doing right now
because if you're relying on AI or
automation
uh if you're relying on those things to
create personalization and you're not
doing it now as a regular business
practice it won't happen
oh is just gonna say with the rise of AI
and all the helpful things that machine
learning can do in terms of modern your
social media and paying attention to you
do you think people will start to get
suspicious of that when it becomes
obvious that the personalization is
machine generated how are people going
to manage that I mean what point does it
stop being personalization and just seem
automated yeah now this is a different
form of personalization I'm glad you
brought it up I I saw a t-mobile ad the
other day and in this ad they made a
promise that when you call customer
support you're going to talk to a human
and not a chatbot now I thought that was
amazing
that you know within the buzz words for
the next year and people were excited
about AI chat BOTS and machine learning
here's t-mobile saying you know what
you're going to get a person and they're
saying where you're going to get a
person because three respect you and you
know when it comes to tech problems
they're one of the most stressful things
that people have to go through and you
have every right to talk to a person and
not a machine
I thought that was bold and I think that
is in response to what people think
about chat BOTS and AI I one of the
biggest issues that I have seen as far
as resistance to that is empathy i chat
BOTS have no and when you have a problem
yeah I guess they'll just be a couple
more years before the anything they work
out that touring test for I think in
that but but pretty soon people people
going to see to it anyway yeah and
there's you know there's wit there's a
place in a time for the chat BOTS um you
know it it's when you try to push them
into what our high-stress situations or
high motion situations that the
frustration will grow quickly and you
know people hang up or just stop
so you know for ordering pizza yeah I
have no problem with a chatbot uh
because chances are uh
you know they're going to get my order
correct so for small things where there
are clear instructions or a clear menu
of options chatbots are great but when
them to more support when there's
problems yeah that's when the empathy
kicks in yeah and what's your
recommendation for doing this at scale
then um boy that that's good that again
that comes back to you what are you
doing right now before the technology
comes what is your business doing right
now because you know human traits are
empathy emotion creativity and what you
it's very difficult if not impossible to
automate that so if you have plans and
you have procedures in place to deal
with this personalization to deal with
customer care then that will make it
easier when the technology comes in and
then starts to scale see the issue and I
say this many times especially when it
comes to CRM x' and things like that I'm
overwhelmed by the amount of people that
will make a decision to buy a CRM but
then when it comes time to implement the
CRM are shocked when they have to then
develop 300 emails for different
scenarios because they were under the
impression that we'll marketing
automation that means the computer does
it I don't so it's impossible to
automate what you don't do all right
that's really the bottom line that's a
great point let's move on to answer
content here a couple of people asked
questions about content specifically the
HEV is pioneering new system of
decentralized content creation with our
community driven content engineer aplay
singh influencer marketing the process
so I know that kind of goes back to you
influencer stuff but it's all about
content what are your thoughts about
that one word
quality produce less content but produce
better content that would be my main
direction um I've worked with a couple
of enterprise brands over the past few
years and they have discovered this as
well that developing a lot of content
doesn't work producing less content but
produced better and higher quality is
will what it works and so you know
content that doesn't educate inform or
entertain is worthless and so you're
saying even tons of little articles are
not as important as just having the
right size articles that are meaningful
and relevant rightly absolutely well and
that's a thing you know a short written
content piece of maybe a hundred words
with a graphic maybe all I need for that
particular purpose um on the other side
I I just I was on a website the other
day and I subscribed to it and I can't
remember what it was the article was a
4,000 word article but they had
interactive content within the article
that was so engaging it was incredible
and so I mean I read the entire article
I engaged with these little interactive
and it was all based on live data and I
could adjust these live data points and
see things and again it was quality it
was the presentation it was so high
quality uh and so you know the problem
so much is it so much users attention is
that well no one's going to give
attention to your white paper that's it
that's basically an ad yeah yeah that's
that's what it comes down to what's the
purpose I mean do you see a future for
long white papers and content like that
even on the b2b side and they do and
especially how's that going to affect
SEO good solid research will always be
the man because it's information it's
good content it's learning
about things that affect my industry the
thing is you're going to have to get
better at presenting it so whether it's
not so much a PDF but maybe it you know
it's a online with interactive charts or
data based on it you know incoming data
streams from different sources uh it's
really that the quality of content and
how you present it it just you know
being lazy about content is not going to
work so and I don't think it matters
anything about the number of words if
you put quality stuff out there that
people need that they use to make
decisions with that they you know it
will help them do better in their job
that's what people want it's a good
gauge for for all content and everything
and now let's move on to email marketing
so we have a lot of people asking about
that so what so yeah it worked one of
the big changes and what do you see for
the future I'll tell you what from all
the analytics that I've been looking at
from multiple companies from enterprise
to SMB to uh you know lone lone wolf
operations email is growing as an active
Channel uh it is powerful it you know I
think a lot of this is CRM and
automation coming into it and the
companies that are planning that again
they're planning that customer journey
they're planning communications they're
creating trigger-based emails so again
the relevance factor is high that if I
get a triggered email it's because of
something I just did something I just
looked at or an event that just happened
that I'm familiar with and so the email
that I receive is highly relevant uh so
email marketing the influence of that
very high and I don't see it lowering
its uh the influence is great and you
know when you look at the return from
email it's fantastic uh it's it's one of
the channels that I
still I'm just excited about now I think
someone had a question about subject
lines and open yeah whether
what's the are there any particular
metrics as far as what's working in
terms of sub subject lines length they
were asking what I know that's a tough
thing because it's the answer is often
it depends and oh yeah Zig line is if
every word in your subject line is
relevant then that's it doesn't matter
how many words it is but it I've looked
at benchmarks of the last year I don't
want to take from your the expert here
but I've seen so many different stories
on it that it's hard to give one
definitive answer but what what have you
seen and also specifically people are
asking about emojis whether that's still
a thing yeah um okay this is yours what
I love about subject lines like you Dan
I've seen read research into length of
the subject line personalization uh what
else um emojis being used time of day
day of week all these things none of
them really show quantifiable
differences among themselves the primary
factor is personal relevance and let me
define that personal relevance is if I
get your email right now how interesting
or relevant is it to me right now that's
the key it may be relevant to me later
on in the day it may be relevant to me
next week but when I see that email in
my inbox
that's the determining factor how
interesting or relevant is the content
to me right now that is the biggest
determining factor to open and click
rates and that's why your highest open
and click rates are triggered marketing
triggered emails because they're based
on what I just did what I just saw what
I just looked at that's why I relevance
so those have the highest opening click
rates yeah I'm starting to see a theme
here relevance in your content
made stuff relevance in your relevancy
quality and relevance of quality we
talked a bit about the voice enable
search so I'm going to skip to that
because we're running out of time here
and want to make sure we get to
everything but what do you have do you
have anything to say about marketing
automation and what so what's the store
for that particularly with images email
products and now if you if you don't
have a good system for for do personal
the relevant your customers marketing
automation is gonna be harder to deploy
yeah honestly it's a good question for
marketing automation I alluded to this
earlier I'd simply like to see the
companies that have Marketo and HubSpot
actually use them to their fullest
capabilities before chasing something
new I just talked to a business the
other day that as a marketing automation
platform they were frustrated with it
and they asked me to get on the call
with that marketing platform and them
and and the ultimate result was well it
wasn't completely installed it's it's
running on you know like a forty five
percent capacity and the client had not
finished the work they needed to fully
implementing again it came back to I
bought it it should work what more do I
have to do uh so many companies have
invested in these systems but they have
yet to use them to their capacity again
you can't automate what you don't have
and so that would be my wish for the
future of automation platforms is that
companies would actually do the work to
use them to their fullest capability I
after that I you know everything gets
easier um so that that kind of circles
back to someone's previous question
about what type of people can you hire
for this and it seems like if you've got
a marketing automation you really need
to bring in the marketing automation
expert and that's probably true for any
yes market well marketing automation
expert content um content people but
also I would call them content
visionaries content visionaries of what
do people need right now and what
coming up scenarios what you know what
about customers in this demographic or
in this ferma graphic who are doing this
what message can we give them so it's
that content visionary being able to
come up with how do we engage people at
different points through their journey
and what do we want them to do and how
do we measure that
so it's people who can ask those
questions who can develop those plans
they are going to be the ones that are
going to be the most valuable moving
forward right well call it looks like we
only have time for another couple of
questions here one person chimed in just
asking specifically about whether
Gmail's tabbed interface is still a
major issue in email marketing for 29:2
is that going to impede stuff getting
into the inbox oh yeah Google's not
going to make anything easy um it's you
still need to ask people to you know to
trust it or to put it into their primary
email tab you know those are some of the
things you can do but yeah we can see
when we look at email deliverability um
you know Google is one of the lower uh
email platforms when it comes to
deliverability and tabbed interfaces is
still you know one of the primary things
that I believe causes that going back to
paid search is there anything that
people can do to fight ad fraud like
click flooding and click injection and
the SDK spoofing because uh Verte Iser
is like Billy tens of billions in 28
yeah it's going to happen you know it's
ad fraud is taking place at a global
level
um I mean it's at the level of organized
crime uh the technology that they're
using what they're doing is just
phenomenal I tell you what from an SMB
perspective there's absolutely nothing
you can do uh you know look at your
reports educate yourself it's the
enterprise level where you're going to
see more of it
however it's hard to spot because you
know programmatic buying it works and it
delivers and so it's harder to find the
fraud within that uh and that's a thing
it's not so much the marketers that have
the ability to fight this it's the
platform's uh you know it's the Google's
the Facebook's uh you know what
responsibility do they bear for people
using their platforms to make you know
to perform this fraud you know there's
not a lot the average marketer can do
unfortunately when it comes to that yeah
and as the artificial intelligence is me
looking products that come up to fight
fraud then it just is that arms race it
goes back and forth yeah they're using
AI to create it to yeah absolutely have
to limit great I think that's all the
time we have today for all these
questions I want to say thank you to
everyone there is so many great
questions and especially we're going to
thank you Matt because and invite people
to reach out to you at Matt Daley says
thanks again to Matt for joining us and
remember to visit simply learn comm /
digital marketing for info on how to
learn more best practices tweet us at
simply learn they needed and appreciate
it and my pleasure and a very prosperous
new year for all of us
[Music]